[Music]
on this friday night delicate and
critical mission the canadian veterans
helping ukrainian women and children
escape war we're here for the long haul
as husbands and fathers stay behind to
defend their country the un's new
investigation into mass graves in
mariupol and russia's shifting strategy
as its offensive stalls the federal
boost of cash meant to relieve surgical
backlogs why experts say this won't
solve the problem plus who betrayed anne
frank and her family sort of a disregard
for historical facts and evidence
controversial claims in a canadian
author's new book
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jackson proskow
hi there and thanks for joining us
russia may be walking back its military
goals in ukraine tonight as vladimir
putin's invasion falters today the
kremlin said it will now focus on
seizing the eastern region of dawn bass
that's where russian-backed separatists
have been fighting since 2014. the u.s
believes russian troops are no longer
advancing on the capital of kiev and
they may have lost full control of the
city of hirson tonight u.s president joe
biden is in neighboring poland visiting
u.s troops and ukrainian refugees
and in ukraine new details are emerging
about the grim situation in mariopol
where officials say hundreds of people
were killed while hiding from russian
bombs crystal commansing begins our
coverage
rubble and confusion these are some of
the first images from inside a theater
in mariupol after a russian missile
strike march 16th
the basement was being used as a bomb
shelter the cell phone video shared
widely as officials broke the grim news
that roughly 300 people may have died in
that building
there's barely anything left of mariupol
the city cut off from life-saving
supplies and basic necessities for weeks
claiming the first stage of the
so-called russian operation has been
generally accomplished senior russian
defense official sergey ratskoye said
attention can now be turned to
liberating the dawn bass
that eastern region has seen ongoing
fighting since 2014 after russia first
invaded an annexed crimea the kremlin
recognized the breakaway region as an
independent state days before launching
its full-scale invasion of ukraine the
area is also where some of ukraine's
most experienced combat soldiers are
stationed
still the war and its devastating
effects are being experienced across the
country
ukrainian officials share videos like
this regularly showing that civilians
are dying this strike in har kiev killed
six
near the capital city more devastation
and pain
you can see for yourself what happened
here people were killed
peace negotiations continue but are
described as very difficult
ukraine's foreign minister says his
country would not relinquish its demands
saying in a statement we insist first of
all on a ceasefire security guarantees
and territorial integrity of ukraine
ukraine's president in yet another video
message told his people they are working
to bringing peace closer
but also victory
crystal gomanson global news
london
as the fighting continues the united
nations human rights team says civilian
deaths continue to climb and now there's
growing evidence of mass graves near the
city of mariupol with some appearing to
hold hundreds of bodies
one mass grove we've been able to get
satellite
information on and we estimate that one
of those mass graves holds about 200
people since russian armed forces
launched their attacks on the 24th of
february at least
1035 civilians have been killed and at
least 1
650 injured
now this all comes as the refugee
situation in ukraine hits another
milestone the un says more than 10
million people have been forced to leave
their homes six and a half million
ukrainians are now displaced within the
country and the rest have fled entirely
today u.s president joe biden visited
neighboring poland where he's set to
come face to face with this once in a
generation crisis mike armstrong reports
from poland
it was another busy day at what has been
since the beginning of this crisis one
of the busiest border crossings the
steady flow of refugees from ukraine
into poland continues
this refugee says poland and other
neighbors have helped what she hopes for
most is the end of the war as soon as
possible
even a month in poland is still adding
services this refugee aid center in
warsaw goes online this weekend it's a
joint project with the norwegian group
we cannot
do this on our own the help warsaw's
mayor says is vital his city and the
country are almost overwhelmed close to
two-thirds of the refugees who've left
ukraine have left through poland the
mayor says taking them in is one thing
keeping them is another we need a
relocation scheme of course a voluntary
relocation scheme in europe and in the
world the u.s president is in poland he
set to meet refugees saturday friday he
was briefed by aid organizations one of
the things he discussed is how the war
is going to affect food security not
just in ukraine but in other countries
as well bad news is they're
in the red basket of the world
ukraine and russia
but we the united states are going to do
our part because we're the third largest
producer of wheat in the world and our
canadian friends are going to do the
same thing
this week the biden administration
announced it would provide more than a
billion dollars in humanitarian
assistance and pledged to take in 100
000 refugees
what is creating so many refugees are
situations like this devastation and
death the u.n human rights office admits
it doesn't have a good idea of the
number of dead it will only say it's
identified at least 1035 civilians
who've been killed i say at least
because we do not yet have the full
picture of locations that have seen
intense fighting
now as the number of refugees grows so
does hunger among those left behind it
estimates about one in five ukrainians
still in the country is now having
trouble finding enough to eat
mike armstrong global news krakow poland
[Music]
and a little later in the newscast we'll
show you how ukrainian families
desperate to escape war were able to
call on canadian veterans for help
the invasion of ukraine has hardened
europe's resolve to wean itself off
russian energy supplies to cut off a key
source of income for the kremlin today
the u.s announced a plan to supply
liquefied natural gas to the eu heather
urex west joins us now from washington
and heather will this be enough for
europe to move away from russian sources
jackson the short answer is no europe
just can't afford to do anything like
that even with the help being promised
from the us today and that's because the
numbers just don't add up europe brings
in more than 150 billion cubic meters of
natural gas from russia each year the
u.s is promising an additional 15
billion cubic meters that's just 10
percent of what's needed the u.s isn't
promising more because they can't
deliver it canada can't either there
isn't the infrastructure in place
because there hasn't been the investment
needed and this isn't something you can
change on a dime
these projects take billions of dollars
and they take years to do as canada has
experience takes sometimes a decade to
do so it might it might help in the
short term it feels good but it's not
going to displace russian gas 25 percent
of the russian gas that we are getting
is non-replaceable we have
either to continue to finance
putin's war or we have to face recession
so it sounds like europe may have its
hands tied in the short term but could
that change
well putin's actions have certainly put
a pla plan in motion that will see
europe move away from russian energy as
quickly as they can germany released a
report today that would see its russian
imports cut in half by mid-summer with
the country completely off of russian
oil and gas by 2024.
it is possible but markets need
certainty they need commitments from
customers that if they invest they will
see the return jackson heather yorks
west in washington thanks heather
three more pediatric cancer patients
from ukraine have arrived in toronto for
treatment the hospital for sick children
says they arrived with their families
from poland wednesday dr summit gupta
traveled with them and says they're
settling in nicely
i have to say the resilience of these
children who having had their lives
completely disrupted can still laugh at
silly jokes or enjoy beating adults i.e
myself at card games is really quite awe
inspiring
sick kids hospital is now caring for
five cancer patients from ukraine
the federal government is promising to
transfer two billion dollars in top-up
payments to the provinces and
territories to help tackle surgery
backlogs the health minister says
unprecedented pressures exacerbated by
the pandemic are putting the health
system at risk but as abigail beeman
reports some say there are other more
effective ways to deal with the problem
a happy and active six-year-old now i
feel better jocelyn ellison was living
with constant pain and urinary tract
infections due to kidney problems a hold
on so-called non-urgent surgeries due to
pandemic backlogs meant she had to wait
a year for the surgery she finally got
in january it goes pee but it don't hurt
anymore
jocelyn is one of hundreds of thousands
of canadians forced to wait too long for
procedures if she had her surgery sooner
it could have saved her a lot of
suffering that she's been through it
could have saved her a lot of
embarrassment at school we have some
very important news
friday ottawa announced two billion
dollars for provinces and territories to
address the surgical backlog this major
investment could help provinces and
territories clearing hundreds of
thousands of backlog surgeries
that's in addition to 4 billion promised
a year ago but short of the 6 billion
the liberals promised to invest quote
immediately in the last campaign i think
we are really just starting to
understand the tip of the iceberg in
terms of the impact of these backlogs
and slowdowns provinces have long been
calling for permanent increases to
health transfers to the tune of almost
30 billion not top-ups which aren't as
effective at dealing with things like
critical staffing shortages some experts
dealing with the devastating impact of
backlogs first hand say unless you
tackle root causes such as staffing and
bed shortages money won't solve the
problem if you created an environment
where people got sicker
people's illnesses were not being
detected
and they were moving into the next stage
of cancer or als or whatever else are
you really winning about those permanent
health transfers friday the health
minister laid out a series of priorities
which sound more like strings attached
something provinces have been very
opposed to do khloe says this list
including access to family doctors
addressing backlogs and staffing and
long-term care is a list of consensus
and still on the politics of health care
this week saw the new liberal ndp deal
friday ndp leader jagmeet singh took
credit for the liberals two billion
dollar top-up saying new democrats have
started to deliver results jackson
abigail beeman in ottawa thanks abigail
the first made in canada covid19 vaccine
has been rejected by the world health
organization quebec based medicago which
created the plant-derived vaccine is
partially owned by philip morris
international the largest tobacco
company in the world the who has a
strict policy against engaging with
companies that promote tobacco it's why
the organization has denied the
vaccine's approval for emergency use and
without that the federal government will
not be able to donate doses of the shot
to the kovacs vaccine sharing alliance
health canada has approved the vaccines
used for people aged 18 to 64.
plastic inside our bodies
coming up how much we could be ingesting
and the health concerns that raises
plus canada's goal to win the world cup
qualifier
[Music]
canada's men's soccer team will have to
wait a few more days to make their world
cup dreams a reality after a tough loss
to costa rica last night the game which
included a controversial red card ended
one to nothing for the home team
canada's next chance to clinch a spot in
the 2022 qatar world cup will be on
sunday when they play jamaica in toronto
a sobering discovery by researchers in
the netherlands they've detected
microplastics in human blood for the
first time the peer-reviewed study found
certain microplastics in nearly 80
percent of the 22 people tested half of
the samples contained p-e-t plastic
commonly used to make drink bottles
the research is considered a
breakthrough despite the small sample
size
we still have to understand where these
particles what happens to these
particles in our body and do they travel
to certain organs do they accumulate
there are they
eliminated by the bile or the kidney
more work is being done to understand
the damage microplastics may cause to
human cells and immune systems it's
believed humans could be ingesting a
credit card's worth of plastic each and
every week
an ice shelf about twice the size of
toronto has collapsed in antarctica
days of unusually warm weather caused
the conjure ice shelf to collapse last
week temperatures had soared to more
than 20 degrees above normal ice shelves
play a critical role in keeping sea
levels from rising too rapidly and
scientists are concerned because east
antarctica has long been considered
relatively stable
ahead the canadian veterans facing war
again to save ukraine's innocent
refugees
[Music]
each day the war rages in ukraine the
road to safety gets tougher for
civilians to find some families who've
been caught in the middle of the
fighting are now out of harm's way in
part because of their connection to two
canadian veterans
jeff semple reports from levite
three ukrainian families arrived at this
bus stop bruised bloodied and
traumatized
their youngest this one-month-old baby
born the same day that russia invaded
it's terrible she says we left
everything behind our city other family
members our heart
they are the lucky ones arriving here to
the relative safety of levive near the
polish border after escaping mariupol
they recorded these images of what's
left of their home
my sons are still there she says there
was nothing left but scorched earth just
hell that burns again and again their
escape from that living hell was made
possible in part by a couple of canadian
veterans we're looking at one of the one
of the places in here
keenan walper and dave lavery served in
afghanistan and until recently they were
working to help their former afghan
interpreters to escape the taliban
controlled country but when russia
invaded ukraine the veterans turned
their gaze to europe we said we're
coming out here right away to see what
we can do they've set up shop on the
polish side of the ukrainian border
sending aid in and getting people out
including these two women who previously
worked as interpreters for the canadian
forces in ukraine
part of operation unifier launched back
in 2015 to train ukrainian soldiers to
defend against a simulated russian
invasion but they never expected to wake
up to the real thing i got really scared
like my my hands they were shaking so
much her hometown was one of the first
in putin's war path with russian jets
flying overhead and bombs falling all
around she knew she had to leave the
hardest part was to get out of sumu
it was blocked from different sides
there were russian tanks and russian
convoys everywhere so she reached out to
her canadian military contacts who put
her in touch with kenan i said you need
to go at the next opportunity but her
rescue required a logistical feat unlike
anything they'd attempted in afghanistan
she was trapped on the other side of
europe's second largest country you're
talking great distances here we're
talking you know 800 kilometers each way
and
obviously the risk is huge using
contacts inside ukraine keenan's team
coordinated a cross-country journey that
involved vehicles trains and multiple
bomb shelters along the way all while
avoiding airstrikes shelling and
fighting after a several day trek she
finally arrived in poland and is now
working with the team to rescue more
former interpreters and other families
still trapped dave lavery says they're
just getting started we'll do as much as
much as we can as long as we can we're
here for the long haul one of the main
differences between their rescues here
and in afghanistan
is this
in ukraine the men can't leave required
to stay behind and fight lavery met this
family on the ukrainian side the young
father said goodbye to his wife and baby
and lavry promised to look after them
somebody's entrusting you
with
their
precious when you hand somebody your
family like that
[Music]
yeah it's gut-wrenching
even for hardened veterans the horrors
of this war can be too much to take
jeff semple global news la viv
backlash and bold accusations next the
disputed new book about the holocaust's
most famous victim
decades after she wrote it anne frank's
diary remains a powerful and harrowing
account of the horrors of the holocaust
but a new book about the teen is facing
backlash after making a bold claim about
who may have betrayed her family ross
lord explains
and frank's first hand account of hiding
out from the nazi gestapo her diary is
universally beloved it details her
harrowing existence along with the
everyday concerns of a young teenager
before she was captured and died in a
concentration camp at the age of 15.
this new book is encountering resistance
for its explanation of how the nazis
found anne frank and her family it
claims the frank family's hideout a
secret annex in what was her father's
office building was exposed by another
jew supposedly a notary named arnold
vandenberg the allegation followed a
six-year investigation led by a former
fbi agent
but jewish community leaders in europe
and historians say the allegation is
flimsy and tarnishes anne frank's memory
jewish leaders in canada also have
concerns it's an approach to history
that is sort of sensationalized
for profit that i think i have
like trouble with in the netherlands a
report by war historians this week
concluded the book did not stand up to
professional scrutiny the book's dutch
publisher has recalled it from
bookstores and is urging other
publishers to do the same but in a
statement english language publisher
harpercollins says it continues to stand
by the publication of the betrayal of
anne frank adding the investigation that
led to the book was done with the utmost
care for an extremely sensitive topic
a statement from the author canadian
rosemary sullivan says although i was
not involved in the research process i
have full confidence in the
investigation disappointing to jewish
leaders who say guarding against
misinformation is more important than
ever at a time when anti-semitic hatred
based on lies is increasing it's um sort
of a disregard for historical fact and
evidence that i guess they both share
and that is incredibly problematic when
we are working so hard to um to present
fact and um and to preserve the voices
of
and the evidence the historical evidence
of what really happened canada's largest
bookstore indigo declined to comment
ross lord global news
and that's global national for this
friday night i'm jackson proskow we
leave you tonight with canada's future
lgbtq2 plus national monument to be
built in ottawa by 2025. the design
revealed this week is inspired by a
thunderhead storm cloud symbolizing
strength activism and hope
thanks for watching dallas flex hog will
be at the anchor desk tomorrow have a
great weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
you